all right guys
bang bang lunch money time well wall
street's trying to get rid of us let's
try to get our lunch money right i'm
here with the beautiful intelligent
polina ebilova marinova
she's obviously very excited i slept 11
hours
oh my god don't forget the lunch jesus
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
block five has three products you can
buy and sell crypto you can take out a
us dollar loan against your crypto
collateral or you can use
my favorite product as an investor and a
user of the product which is their
interest bearing accounts
you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy in those interest bearing
accounts
go check it out block fi.com pom
locify.com
she got it 11 hours look at that she
remembers the ads all right
what's up with the first topic there is
a whale
that has been unmasked so soft bank
group shares tumbled in tokyo after
reports that the japanese conglomerate
made substantial bets on
equity derivatives amid the surge in
technology
stocks so basically masa masayoshi sun
is taking over the nasdaq can you tell
us well
basically what they're doing is they're
using derivatives right so if you
if you uh understand what derivatives
are they're basically you're not buying
actual stock
you're basically betting on the future
price of those stocks is the derivative
different from an option
it's the same thing that yeah they're uh
an option is a type of derivative
uh and so if you think about um
the softbank business they have
access to a lot of capital uh literally
billions and billions and billions and
billions of dollars if you remember
they've got the soft bank vision fund
100 billion dollars
for the private markets uh the joke
always was that
uh softbank could impact private market
valuations because they could flood the
market with so much capital
uh but now it looks like they're doing
the same thing in the uh public markets
they've started a new unit
to trade in the public markets what does
it say that they do
uh what do you mean the new unit oh it's
it uh
targets investments of more than 10
billion perhaps tens of billions
and would use financing structures that
would allow the company to avoid showing
up in public
disclosures of shareholding basically
they're putting
literally tens of billions of dollars
into the market they're doing it where
they don't actually have to put on the
annual filings
and on top of all of that uh they're
using these
options uh and derivatives to
uh specifically speculate in tech stocks
which led this massive bull market uh
and now they basically got kind of uh
identified as
being that way if they don't show up in
public disclosures how were they
identified as the whale
oh i mean there's much somebody
literally could have leaked it somebody
that one of their counterparts that they
trade with i mean i thought that was
like a public way to discover this but i
guess not
yeah no but but i do think that uh it's
pretty damn interesting
all righty what's next patreon whose
platform lets creators independent
creators earn money from fans through
subscriptions
has raised 90 million dollars in new
funding at a valuation of 1.2 billion
and is planning to use the money to
expand internationally and beef up
tools for creators well
we know you're a big fan of sub stack
what about patreon
look again anytime that you can help the
people
pay creators for their content it's
pretty damn cool
um i think that uh what you're seeing is
more and more people are realizing
uh that the rise of the creator is a
trend that's already been occurring
right whether this is on youtube whether
this is writing
patreon one of the pioneers of this
right start seven years ago yeah
uh but the second thing is that there
just wasn't a lot of infrastructure in
place so people were using tools that
had been created really for small
businesses
uh they weren't kind of creator specific
tools patreon was one of the first ones
that was
uh kind of creator specific because
ultimately what it does is
in a lot of cases it allows you to
either support
yeah without anything extra like just
hey i think you're doing a great job
with support
and then also it allows creators to like
put things behind hey if you're one of
my supporters on patreon you'll also get
abc
my my problem with paint not know that
it's a problem but my thought about
patreon and the reason i didn't really
think about it for my newsletter is one
i like substance but two
um the whole idea of gratuity like that
somebody's leaving me a tip for
i i didn't like that it's a product
you're paying for it you know what i
mean but you can do that on patreon i
think now you can i think it used to be
like that and that just like stayed well
people kind of hack it right what they
say is like if you're a supporter of
buying on patreon you'll get
extra okay it's like i'll send you
content
[Music]
i think whereas sub stack had the
reputation of i'm paying for this
product and i want a subscriber right
yeah it's just one is very uh specific
use case one had more flexibility but
isn't this amazing that today patreon
has more than 200 000 creators on its
platform
who have collectively earned two billion
dollars that's pretty
significant and robust six million
subscribers which the
company refers to as patrons i i like
this quote the stigma of the starving
artist
is going to fade away true very true
all right what's next virgin galactic
bang bang space
okay virgin galactic plans to conduct
its next
crude space flight do you think
tom cruise going to be on it on october
22nd
the flight will be the first of two that
the space tourism company has planned to
complete testing of its spaceship two
spacecraft system instead of just two
test pilots on board okay i mean
but then the next one will have four and
if both test flights succeed
then virgin galactic expects to fly
their founder richard branson
in the first quarter he always said that
he's been saying this since 2017.
i interviewed so richard branson once do
you think do you think that he's
actually going to get on the uh
flight he'll get on i don't think it's
going to be in the first quarter of 2021
why it's not ready it's absolutely epic
that richard branson is claiming he's
going to go to space but
but it's space tourism i don't
understand and we can
look at this later how are they actually
going to go into space or are they just
talking about going into like
the outer part of the atmosphere i i
believe it's the outer atmosphere
is it yeah they just they just loop yeah
i mean i i don't know right uh but
basically that that's one of the key
things it's not like they're going to
the international space no
no no no no no right but look by the way
either way it's super cool
like if they actually do have commercial
tourism uh
in space i don't care if you're in the
outer atmosphere
you're in real space wherever the fact
that like an average person
could be able to go do this is nuts
wait can i tell my favorite richard
branson story sure okay
so if you read i i read one of his books
and in it there was an anecdote where he
says when he was in school
he was kind of a troublemaker so one of
his teachers told him uh you're either
going to end up in prison or you're
gonna end up being a millionaire
and he goes i ended up neither i'm a
billionaire
okay lg lg
okay this is kind of ridiculous so
there's cloth face masks as we all know
there's a little bit some of them are a
little more elevated
but lg is now showcasing it's pure care
wearable air purifier a consumer
electronics and home appliance
at the at the trade show um but it's
basically
an advanced air purifier mask that makes
most face coverings
look ancient by comparison so let's show
you the picture
it has like literally it's like legit
it's it looks like you're uh
darth vader it's got like a whole thing
that you put on your face
and it's got a filter to it and it's got
some kind of air purifier so literally
imagine if you took like
yeah like everything like a gas mask
type thing looks like a futuristic gas
mask that they're essentially
trying to uh to sell to people it's
equipped with a respiratory sensor that
detects the cycle and volume of the
wearer's breath
and it adjusts the dual three speed fans
accordingly
this is a little too much i mean i mean
if you're in like a super
serious situation sure sounds great
you'll definitely wish that you had one
of these that's true if you're walking
down the street in new york city
honestly also like pollution yeah well
definitely there's
places that have high levels of
pollution but like my whole thing has
always been
uh if you're walking outside not near
anybody
i know but most dense cities it's hard
to walk without encountering people
right
true true so i mean look it it's uh it's
really interesting now you're gonna see
this boom
of like not only face masks but you're
gonna see a boom
of uh technologically enabled
face masks and so you know do we get to
a world where everyone's walking around
with like gas masks on
probably not but you know weirder
stranger things have happened in 2020.
so speaking of weirder things in 2020 so
all these like young people are starting
businesses in the pandemic that kind of
um
use the pandemic to you know to fuel
their business
benefits one such uh business
a senior at vassar had some income from
an internship but it wasn't enough to
keep
her her family financially secure so she
started an online tarot reading
business so this tarot reading business
she uses an etsy shop and she offers
appointments with social distancing
customers can opt for a taped reading or
live on online reading
they ask to know about life love and
past lives
tarot reading is a tool to reflect back
deep
truths about yourself that we already
know
okay here's here's i like
entrepreneurship i don't know if i'm
into the tarot card reading stuff but
let me tell you so when i was at fortune
one of my first articles that i wrote
was called million
million dollar psychics and it was these
like crazy psychics that charged
a lot of money and they charged
corporations whatever
their businesses boomed during the
recession the last recession
because of the uncertainty people wanted
to know what do i do with my money
should i sell everything like people
were gen there was this one woman who
claims that she predicted the financial
crisis
laura reed i think is her name but she
she's legit we're not we're not
advertising any terrorists no no we're
not she's legit like famous for that
and i called her and asked her like what
the hell and she was like yeah people
were calling me and asking me like
should i sell my barn and i was like i
think so
and like i if you're calling a tarot
card reader to make investment decisions
you probably shouldn't be managing money
well people are
so that's so sure they call themselves
like intuitives and
i just i think that it's kind of preying
on people in my opinion because
most aren't legitimate but tarot cards
is basically like let me tell you about
yourself you know
my whole thing on all of this the
psychics
all this kind of stuff is there is no
evidence
whatsoever that suggests that it is real
and to me if you want to be a
therapist you have to get a license i
don't think you have to get a license to
be a psychic
or a tarot actually people have been
trying to kind of like
to like legitimize this industry or
regulate it
but it's not yet it's not yeah so you
should have to go get a license
and that should have like super strict
things to take out all the con artists
and all the nonsense because there are
many are there people who
uh can present information from an
entertainment standpoint
but there's an argument to be made that
i think the value well
the value of religion is simply to give
people peace of mind
right and like control populations and
do all this stuff not in like a negative
way but just like
people are uncertain about the future
therefore if they are religious
that gives them some level of uh
certainty
and um makes them less anxiety and like
all that kind of although
i one time in college got a tarot card
reading by another student
and i freaked out she said crazy things
and i was like oh my god my life is
going to hell i had anxiety for like two
months i'm never doing that again
anyway so it doesn't work if you're
looking for entertainment but you're an
anxious person don't do it
you see how her decision-making has
improved now that she knows me
uh but but you have like in new york
city you have been seeing more of those
like psychics on the streets
but my point is if their promise is like
hey i'll basically calm you
down so that you're not like worried
about the future it does the same thing
that religion does
okay but when you start to actually
present yourself as like
a like a medical ex like hey i'm to tell
you whether you should get surgery or
not for this medical condition
or i'm going to tell you whether you
should sell all of your
physical goods and like go put your
money in gold
like those types of things it's like now
you're actually giving advice well you
know why they which is dangerous you
know why they won't calm you down
why because when you go they want to
upsell you and the way they upsell you
is the types of people that go they say
um i'm seeing like a dark energy around
you for 200
i can cleanse that and then they'll see
something else and something like
witches
well it's like you know that's that that
right there was a kind of what i don't
want to say no like they just
they just try to upsell you they're
entrepreneurs
what let's go to the next topic so
a majority of young adults in the u.s
roughly
uh hold on okay
are living with their parents for the
first time since the great depression
so majority meaning over 50 percent of
young adults how do they categorize 18
to 29 year olds in the us
are living with their parents uh 52
now live with one or both with one or
both of their parents up from 47 in
february
all right that's actually pretty
material it's more than a 10 increase
yeah but 47
of february where are there so many
people living at home huh
i feel like 47 in february was high
well no no i mean this is a trend that's
definitely been going on right
but now what you're seeing is this
massive explosion
uh more than ten percent growth since
february i would have actually thought
that it could have been
higher in the growth since february but
i would not have guessed that the number
in february
it has surpassed the previous peak
during the great depression era
yeah i mean that's uh that's that's
crazy
uh i think it i mean look it it's
definitely a trend people knew that this
was happening
18 to 29 year olds are living at home
get out your mom's basement they should
have included like up to 30. i feel like
there's a lot of people who move back
here's uh what people are wait when you
turn 30 you move back no no i think
there's an
a lot of people in that age range who
left like the city and moved back with
their parents
oh well that's the other thing too is
like how sustainable it is right i mean
if they're just counting people who like
let their lease expire in new york move
back with their family until the end of
the year then they're coming back to new
york like
okay sure what they can't yet because
they don't know what people are gonna do
maybe they survey them and ask what they
plan on
uh but definitely that that's a little
unique
anyway i think and young adults have
been particularly hard hit by this
year's pandemic and economic downturn
we've talked about that before because a
lot of their jobs are seasonal and like
part time my mom would love if i moved
back home
i'm sure my mom would be so happy it'd
be great she'd cook me dinner every
night
it would be amazing are you saying i
don't cook you dinner
no no i'm just saying like hang out my
mom for like
a week and then i'd be like okay i gotta
get out of here
[Music]
am i dogs oh man they'd be hype all
right can you imagine if i hung out all
right moving on my two dogs every day
that'd be
ready to chill moving on i just dropped
my phone in the bath
wait for what oh it's a joke okay we're
on the jokes
i just dropped my phone in the bathtub
it's now sinking
you get it you get it i get the syncing
with a y
and syncing with an i in c i just don't
think it's funny
i thought it was hilarious all right
guys that's it for lunch money i know
i know i know i told you we were going
to do it yesterday
we didn't do it it's my fault we won't
get into it
it was my fault i woke up he didn't have
11 hours of sleep
and i just said nah i'm not doing it
today
it's not gonna do it but i'm back today
i woke up today so i'm gonna do it today
so here we are all right that's it for
lunch money we'll talk to you guys
tomorrow
well while she's trying to get rich
russell was just trying to get her lunch
money right and plane is sleeping for 11
hours and hitting herself in the
forehead
see ya bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends